welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and did we just get our first
official deadpool mcu crossover no
maybe i don't know what constitutes mcu
canon anymore
considering we learned who newmaster 69
was from
an xbox live commercial and if marvel is
willing to let
korg from the thor movies appear
alongside deadpool and the promo for
free guy
sure why the hell not a lot of you guys
have been hitting me up about this promo
spot that ryan reynolds released in
promotion for his upcoming movie free
guy
so i figured i'd do a quick reaction to
this because it is interesting to talk
about how deadpool is gonna show up in
the mcu and we might have gotten some
clues in this
my reaction to someone else reacting to
a trailer what am i the real reject
so i'm just gonna react to the final bit
of this and give you my thoughts and
theories and all of it so here
we go any tips on uh getting into the
mcu there court
uh have a dream uh chase it
lose that dream just sabotage all sorts
of happiness in pursuit of that dream
climb up to the peaks of that mountain
and when you get to the top
land at the bottom and realize you're
never going to achieve that dream
and at that point check your emails
maybe you'll get something from your
agent saying
marvel wants to talk yeah i prefer dark
world
half a [ __ ] penny of you for this
[Laughter]
awesome so yeah obviously this is
deadpool and korg
reacting to the latest promo for free
guy which happens to start both ryan
reynolds and taika with tt so i
imagine that's how they were able to put
this promo together but they put a lot
of vfx
into cork he looks great here that's why
deadpool was joking at the end that they
must have spent a lot of money on this
particular promo and yeah i love how he
says he prefers dark worlds which
you know an underappreciated marvel
movie
especially as we're watching loki i feel
like between endgame
and loki these marvel titles keep going
back to reference the events of thor of
the dark world and i like how he calls
himself canadian cumberbatch
kind of like regretting that he's been
diverted away from his next deadpool
movie coming in the mcu but calling
himself cover badge is just interesting
i mean could we say that deadpool could
make an appearance in multiverse of
madness
a doctor strange variant an alternate
reality sorcerer supreme so throughout
the reaction deadpool kind of jokes how
this is a fox disney fire sale kind of
thing right
okay this looks fun in a in the last
days of fox fire sale kind of way
and that's what free guy kind of is it
was a fox studios production that was
already in development
already started pre-production and then
they shot it as disney's acquisition of
all of fox's properties began so now in
addition to
all the production and release delays
that kovid caused
free guy is just kind of in this weird
space where a lot of people are like is
this movie still happening
which might explain why disney's willing
to pour all this vfx and ip releases
into this particular promo but what's
exciting about this is
deadpool 3 is happening at marvel
studios there is a script being written
right now by the molly news sisters who
wrote in bob's burgers and if we're
talking about ways deadpool could show
up in the mcu with shows like loki
entitles beyond this like doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness marvel
studios is starting to give us all
kinds of ways that deadpool could easily
just blip up into this reality
and i love how in this trailer reaction
deadpool makes these jokes about
fridging
jody calmer god i love her so much oh i
hope they don't fridge her
which she explains is this idea of where
they take a female character and they
either kill her off or make her suffer
in order to make the male protagonist
react and have a catalyst for his next
move which he admits is something that
deadpool 2 kinda did but before i
continue this video is sponsored by
sheath underwear sheaths boxers are
designed to keep your bits gently
separated for maximum comfort
sheath has three individual compartments
to keep everything down there separate
cool and most importantly comfortable
the design of traditional boxer briefs
can make all your different parts stick
together and sweat and then start to
chafe
while sheath has a modern ergonomic
design intended to prevent skin on skin
contact see they've got this inverted
kangaroo pouch for your joey to cut down
on chafing and readjusting
you you got one pouch here another pouch
for that guy and then everybody's
hanging out
having a good time you know when you
gotta readjust
it's never really a great look unless
you play professional baseball and you
know even then
come on sheath were invented by a us
army soldier who came up with the idea
for sheets during his second tour in
iraq where that super hot climate
prompted some serious discomfort for the
unmentionables so click the link below
and use the code new rockstars at
checkout or go to sheath underwear dot
com
new rockstars for 20 off and do your
boys a favor that sheath underwear dot
com or just click the link below and use
the code new rockstars for 20
off but while we're thinking about
deadpool 2 remember how that movie ended
he
turned back time using cable's
wristwatch that allowed them to go back
in time and that's where the deadpool
franchise left off
so already all the work is done to just
have deadpool spiraling through the time
stream and through some events of
loki or through doctor strange's
multiverse of madness all those feuding
timelines with their incursion sparks
with each other from one of those
deadpool just kind of shows up now we
had a lot of theories similar to this
with evan peters showing up in
wanovision saying that the west view hex
may have opened up some kind of gateway
between universes
and that marvel might have been trying
to bridge the fox x-men
universe with the mcu that ended up not
being the case but looking back evan
peters is kind of representative of a
later era of the x-men movies whereas
deadpool has always kind of been in his
own comedic bubble he's
kind of been a live-action bugs bunny so
whatever universe he wants a cameo in
audiences are just gonna accept it
without asking too many questions about
what that means but what would be
exciting about deadpool showing up is
and the reason why so many of us thought
that evan peters could actually be the
quicksilver from the x-men movies is
that evan peters showed up as
quicksilver in the background of
deadpool 2
one of my favorite cameo moments from
that movie so even if evan peters was
actor ralph boner citizen of westview
new jersey and wandavision
though by the way a name that might have
still been part of the hex
illusion rather than that guy's actual
real name in real life in the mcu it's
still
plausible that evan peters could show up
as quicksilver in the mcu
with the logic now of deadpool showing
up there now notice that can it looks
like either an energy drink or a craft
beer or something like that in the
foreground at first i'm like wait is
that
loki doing this no that's just a still
of guy in this movie but if you do want
to know more about free guy
i did a whole trailer breakdown of it
last year i don't know what time is
anymore but i did go
into a crazy theory at the end of that
that explained that the whole movie
might be a deadpool mcu crossover by the
end of it and with this promo it looks
like that theory might be
kinda sorta maybe maybe not coming true
though i don't think deadpool is gonna
show up in like thor love and thunder or
anything like that that movie is kind of
set on its own path it's doing its own
thing but characters like
korg and some of the more comedic cosmic
goofball mcu characters
like loki like the guardians of the
galaxy could make cameos in deadpool 3.
oh and something i forgot to mention
about fridging that's another kind of
green lantern reference because the term
fridging comes from a green lantern
comic in which green lantern's
girlfriend was stuffed in a fridge
so i love it all of this is just
deadpool making fun of himself anyway
let me know what you thought of this
promo are you
excited to see free guy when it comes
out how do you want deadpool's mcu
entrance to look
comment down below with all your
thoughts and theories be sure to
subscribe and you can support this
channel by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me
at eavos on instagram and twitter follow
new rockstars and we'll see you next
time bye
[Music]
you